data and data ownership where data gets
produced and I mean and also not wanting
to lose sight of wow there's really
amazing things that we can do with data
now right like the data that's being
collected from the hardware devices and
various things at this conference is
amazing right and we want to utilize
that to the best possible way and so the
human data Commons foundation is comes
out of this there's amazing ways that we
can combine and use data there's very
destructive ways that data can be used
there's all sorts of privacy and ethical
concerns this is a very you know this is
a burgeoning field an active discussion
that's happening now I'm super thrilled
to see it happening you know I'm just
hurt overheard you know so many
conversations here about data privacy
and where is it stored and all this kind
of stuff which is just music to my ears
and and so playing some sort of
coordinating role in how that can happen
so that we get the best possible results
and eliminate the worst possible results
is the purpose of the human data Commons
foundation
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sakia we are
at the transformative technology
conference we love being here there's so
many brilliant people here shout out to
our main woman Nicole Bradford we love
you so much and we have the pleasure of
now sitting down with Scott Nelson
what's that man this is my first time at
this conference I sent down our
executive director of our organization
last year to sort of recon it and she
connected with Nicole and Nicole
connected with her obviously and they're
like yeah you guys got to get involved
this time so I'm on a panel tomorrow to
talk about data sovereignty privacy and
user rights yeah that's gonna be a good
one and what you were just teaching me a
moment ago will be unpacking that I'm
super excited huge thank you for coming
on the show yeah we really appreciate it
my pleasure all right so human data
Commons really cool foundation we'll
talk about that we'll talk about the
conference we'll talk about the
quantified self report card it's all
very interesting stuff I'm super excited
for that
let's let's get to know more about you
so who the hell are you how did you even
end up where you're at today okay what's
our take as much as you are okay well
I've always been a computer geek Apple
two plus I did my undergrad at undergrad
work in philosophy philosophy of mind
and philosophy of science and how they
meet or where they meet and then and
started one of the first web development
companies in Canada probably the first
one actually and in 93 and it was
focused all around actually ecological
sustainability who was our focus I
wanted to bring that technology and help
that those sorts of initiatives get out
in front with the new medium so I had
that through the 90s I sold out of that
that
penny and then I became a solo agent for
the next few years got really inspired
by the open source movement and became
what I call that a technology steward
helping progressive organizations again
working around sustainable and
ecological environmental issues to adopt
open source technology and make make a
shift to that technology for what they
were doing and trying to empower them in
that way
and then I got got involved in Bitcoin
in 2010 early user there that touched a
bunch of things for me around privacy
economics technology cryptography all
interests my open source and I kind of
jumped whole hog into into what was
going on there and so I invested a lot
of time and my skills my tech skills are
pretty good around building
infrastructure around that and of course
you know move the dial few years and you
know I have certainly a very different
relationship to capital than I did back
in those days so in that intervening
time I've done a lot to sort of promote
the digital currency and blockchain
ecosystem and looked for ways and also I
mean the other sort of big thing for me
is about 12 years ago I guess I had like
a psycho-spiritual crisis in my own life
really opened up to meditation that's
when I learned about the integral model
and the work of Ken Wilber American
philosopher Ken Wilber greatly impressed
by that that model and so you know where
I'm at now is and why I'm at this
conference is it brings together so many
elements and you know I think we all
have a sense of you know there's some
big problems that need to be tackled
there's a feeling that you know you know
it's probably better to be moving
quickly on addressing some of these
issues rather than dragging our heels
raising human consciousness and
everything around that is I mean
certainly for me an important part of
the solution probably you know the most
expedient solution so how we get there
and so I kind of approached that on a
number of different fronts but you know
the human data Commons foundation is
specifically to look at data and issues
around data and yeah how you got where
you are now together yeah it's very you
know you know you you you picked you
picked a lot of things that resonate
with you know the integral 3 along with
the open sourcing and the economics of
things like Bitcoin and the freedom that
comes and things like that and yeah it
just all kind of you know crunches
together to make what you care about now
and it's cool I like it when it puzzle
kind of seems like it's biased a little
bit because I want it to make sense but
yeah you know we are we are pattern
recognition creatures right so when we
can see a coherent pair you know
coherent pattern emerging and I mean
we're also humans so that means not
everything we do make sense with means
and you know part of the part of the
impetus I guess or why I think this is
so important is I really share the
sensibilities of Yuval Noah Harare
around around the ability for it to be
used to manipulate us and how you know
we really have to look seriously and
it's not just people people act like
it's 10 years old with Facebook and
Twitter and stuff no this is even before
that with the era of Bernays and was it
again cyclic there no no yeah of protein
proteins like for you psycho now
psychoanalysis yeah and and then there's
even before that is with like the food
era and the foods and
there's there's been manipulations even
for the Trojan horse letting in the
Trojan horse you know these things have
been happening for yeah since we started
yeah well I have to tell you thank you
for bringing that up because I actually
skipped over that part of the story and
that is when I got out of the ivory
tower of philosophy in Vancouver where I
studied it my first job was actually the
world's largest public relations firm
and I had no idea what public relations
firm is I have no idea about business
about you know the media any of that
stuff and I land in this office and
we're you know a you know
gigantic multinational corporation this
is in like 92 and I'm like what is this
work we're doing we're like monitoring
the media and they're like you know
setting up these press conferences and
these you know public you know things
and lobbying government stuff and
finally a friend of mine there who kind
of recognized my ethics I was already
you know you know a tree hugger I was
like already Greenpeace supporter and
stuff so you know this was all I kind of
really hard for me to figure out and
he's like here this will help and he
slides a copy of Chomsky's manufactured
consent to I was like holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] that's what I'm doing that's what's
going on and you know it was a very yeah
it was a huge awakening for me about oh
this is you know a really serious part
of how the world works is to look at the
masses as manipul
and you know and that their their their
their behavior can be molded and
sculpted and and forest and so and it
was my experience in that that made me
want to start my own company actually
which I did in 93 when the web was just
emerging so you know that hit all my
computer geek stuff but now I had this
other understanding of sort of
manipulating the world and quite frankly
at least initially I was like oh I cool
I have a cool new tool in my you know in
my toolbox that I can leverage for the
kinds of changes that I think need need
to happen so I always like it when
entrepreneurs
say things like the normal model of the
world that I lived in was not good
enough I wanted to go and change it and
make it better and so another thing that
that you said that resonated with me it
was about how you had you chose to to
observe how how how strange it was when
people feel like they are superior to
other people and they get all
egotistical about it and they go and
they try and make manipulations and
culture and economics and policy for
their favor and then there's this other
sort of mentality of feeling equality
and divinity to other people and that
like equality and divinity and feeling
that and knowing that you were actually
talking about this before we started but
when you baseline someone away from
anger and fear and you baseline them
towards a neutral State mm-hmm in a calm
state a quantum state that they can get
rebase line to a state of happiness and
bliss right yeah yeah so anyway I was
really vibing on the juxtaposition
between those two things as you're
speaking so I wanted to mention it yeah
thank you yeah and I mean you're
alluding there I think to that what
we're talking about but theory you
taking people into a place of stillness
right and then right action will emerge
out of that yeah as being part of it
yeah and that's in it that's a very
important part of sort of our process
and what we try and do as well so you're
in the ivory tower and I mean I was in
the ivory tower you know and in vacuum
90 and I can yeah 1991 and then boom
into the belly of the beast in this
international public relations firm and
then then started my first company after
that and I mean part of the reason that
I started a company is because I had
from familiarity with you know the
various structures forms out there that
one could sort of affect change with and
you know I've probably spent I've always
kind of skirted that line between
nonprofits and
and businesses and stuff you know it's
it's it's much more highly developed now
in terms of the whole notion of social
enterprise and things like this you hear
of but back then and still I mean for
well yeah certainly back then you kind
of had to make a choice which one you
were going to do kind of thing and it
was pretty clear that the corporate form
is the one that has the most freedom to
do whatever it wants in the world as
soon as you're in other structures
you're beholden to much larger
populations or you know the government
in certain ways for you know your VC
charitable tax status and things like
that and so you know choosing the
entrepreneurial route was was in part a
you know there was a certain element of
freedom to do what I wanted kind of
thing do yet yeah but again you you knew
you knew this is a very classic
entrepreneurial pull of of wanting
freedom to build the future and and
wanting to change the war way the world
works is they're not satisfied with the
way it works
so all right so now take us to the first
company take us to where you're building
take us to you how that brushed human
data Commons yeah yeah yeah so I mean
the first the first company as I
mentioned was about bringing web
technology to the sustainability
movement let's just call it that that
included you know corporate government
and nonprofit clients so we kind of
bridge bridge that world doing web dev
for sustainability related projects yes
yeah cool that's right and again it was
kind of the first I think it probably
was the first job development shop it
was it was early and we in fact we were
also doing that with other computer
networks that around were around at that
time I don't know if you were into the
BBS scene or there was also an
international kind of I was born then oh
you were yeah okay never mind
yeah I knew dropping that one on you
would be like here like I don't know
the BBS and I was like I was born then
yeah you know I was an I didn't get to
be there in the news when you guys were
building the first web yeah so you've
been immersed in it your whole life
right you've never known life without
without tech without tech yeah you know
without that tech right yeah yeah so
yeah I mean I I can't really imagine I
don't have children myself and I don't
have a lot of sort of the younger ish
people in my life I ask you why the
choice for the children no children yeah
I mean again it was tied largely to
ecology yeah and yeah yeah yeah I mean
most people don't aren't following the
whole like selfish gene thing they're
not they're not really understanding
that like making a copy of themselves
into the world so unnecessary it's you
know so for some people they feel like
it's it brings them the most meaning
gether life is to do something like yeah
I didn't yeah and for and for me and I
say this frequently is that I just I
like to challenge status close a lot and
an interesting way to challenge the
status quo to be like maybe medics and
disseminating ideas to billions of
people is actually way more impactful
and important for me to do then pop out
one or two kids and you know focus all
my time on those kids so any that's kind
of like my little time yeah yeah I mean
I have to admit I was fortunate that my
partnered never wanted to have kids so
that made it you still with your yeah oh
yeah that is yeah you're very fortunate
that no she didn't you know cuz then now
you're both focusing on your yeah yeah
and she felt actually stronger about it
than I did so that made it easier for me
so that's that's great
yeah it's unusual for sure to have
stories like this cuz most women are
getting categorized into buckets of like
Oh like wanting to have families and
wanting to nurture kids and yeah you
know yeah there's plenty of women that
are like no I don't want to
apparently it's one in five one in five
interesting I recently heard one out of
every five dollars in the United States
is spent on health care interesting
another interesting statistic yeah
that's what I've heard from from a
friend of mine who's researching yeah
but you know I mean for me personally
it's also the case that I think you know
in terms of perpetuating my genes well
that's not necessary I can do whatever I
want with my DNA and I can sell it to
who I want and all of that kind of stuff
that's part of the age that we live in
now so that is no longer sort of
argument and the other thing for me too
was wait a second you're saying that
you're the age we live in is your it's
already now when we got to a point where
you can just sell your sperm to people
that need sperm or the one sperm and
yeah and you can your genes can live in
a way where you don't even have to
nurture the child and somebody else
wants to raise a child that isn't able
to find this for them and yeah and I'm
not at all making the claim that my DNA
is somehow special or something we live
in the age where the genes can spread
without you needed how exactly it's very
interesting exact just that at that
point was young a cool okay continue yes
the other point which I which I think is
valid as well is that if I decided I
felt that I must be a father to some
figure there's so many other
opportunities to do that that don't
require again me bringing another human
into the world I can adopt a child I can
be a foster father or there's all these
other structures and that would allow me
to do that in a meaningful way that
doesn't require you know oh we need more
humans on the planet there's there's a
there's a there's definitely a
difference in the bonding hormone for
when you procreate versus when it is and
I would like to know exactly what the
difference in the bonding
hormone-like Oh an oxytocin may be right
but then you also mentioned ecological
footprint which I thought it's very
interesting
looks like population is gonna stabilize
around nine ten billion people looks
like that and if fingers cross fingers
cross and there's there's a sea there's
significant impact when people choose to
not have kids that's like not using
whatever egregious amount of diapers
whatever egregious amount of electricity
that's not currently again it's not
currently completely sustainable by
solar or something or all right imagine
so so yeah it so there's a lot of
resources that need to be used plastic
bottles or of course some would say have
more than made up for it by getting
involved with Bitcoin which is pretty
balanced okay let's direct this let's
derive this back to the human data
Commons go back there was good that was
yeah okay back to the human data Commons
so yeah okay so my company obvious horse
steward and then blockchain getting into
blockchain or Bitcoin so yeah and then
you know the psycho-spiritual a crisis
of twelve or so years ago and the you
know what was that like for you what was
that feeling well I mean crisis I think
here's yeah important part of it yes
what it feels like definitely feels like
having the rug pulled out from under you
and like a bunch of different way think
you're doing things in a way that's
meaningful and then you get opened up to
something that makes you think that you
want to do it a different way
I would place it more in the category of
existential crisis as in why am I here
what am i doing yeah
and also you know I'm be tied into sort
of my my interest and understanding of
integral theory is the idea that we go
through a series of crises in our lives
as we kind of level up every seven years
well it's it doesn't tie to a strict
schedule nice try not totally strict
yeah somewhat around like that yeah yeah
sure right from birth I'm a completely
different person than I was in high
school of course yeah yeah sure if I
would different one right you're
believing development to me yeah yeah
into all this time here I guess so isn't
it weird when you look back and you're
like I would not have been my own friend
that's so weird to look at that and I
have to ask how long ago was that for
you yeah yeah 26 now so you've got
you've got a cushion there do you just
have your 10-year reunion or I know it
will be I guess in a year or two oh yeah
a reunion of high school yeah yeah
something for you I mean I went to my 10
years it already is it's already strange
even thinking about this I had friends
that are still like working the job that
they worked at when I knew them in high
school yeah like really yeah but it's a
good Union job or whatever the algorithm
is that keeps looping what where where
is the insatiable appetite for growth
and learning and curiosity and yeah
anyway well to some extent that's a
that's a privileged position to be in as
well right to be able to pursue those
kinds of well we also see artists or
entrepreneurs that choose to throw away
all of the privilege of being like I'll
just do the normal path which is
privileged in a sense because when you
go down the out of the beat of the less
walked path you end up living way lower
in socioeconomic status but you find
more meaning in your life and it doesn't
in some ways privilege you to have more
time to
contemplate and make and create so we
got to get past the scarcity we got it
we're gonna get towards abundance square
where people have time to contemplate
their yeah okay so for you that back to
that the Christ the crisis yeah yeah
well I mean I'm kind of excuse me
folding it back into the integral market
because you know each time you move
through a stage a sort of identified
area where you've got a sort of a core
set of beliefs that are your orientation
to the world each time you move to a new
level part of what happens there is you
your old beliefs just aren't holding you
anymore right oh yeah right and like
you're saying you know with your looking
for yourself values your head in high
school right it's like that's not me
anymore and but at that time those were
the the values that provided the meaning
provided the framework you know you were
able to operate in the world with right
but at some point you outgrew those
right those no longer worked for you
weren't you had to move to a new place
right that's a crisis every time because
the old values you're still trying to
hang on to them you're still trying to
make sense of the world with this value
set yet it's not working anymore and so
there's a disjunct happening there and
in integral theory there's certain
transitions which are much harder more
things change and one of them is the one
that happens for all of us in
adolescents that's the first significant
change that we go through and that's why
it's such a troubling time for us yeah
it's trying to figure out what's going
on in our new self is emerging and our
you know our old values which kind of
held us together in our early teens or
whatever word aren't working anymore the
world is a different place you're inside
of the hallways of the school and yeah
they're like so much different yeah yeah
and then the other significant one I
would say is often identified especially
for men with a midlife crisis right so
that's another way I mean also have I
think so but I think maybe in a
different way or or something I to be
honest I have not explored so knock yeah
you're good
I've not explored that side of things to
any extent that I can sort of speak with
any authority about that but but but I
am a believer that there are gender
genuine gender differences like that's
[Laughter]
not a debate whoever is propagating
I'm sick of I'm sick of the alright and
I'm sick of the radical left yes are you
familiar with the intellectual dark well
I am very good we hosted we know Stan
Peterson on the show fantastic Sam and
Eric and you know our great show is
great yeah and and I I here's here's
something that I think it's great that
we can vibe on this that that the the
pursuit of truth although it is under
attack in some sense by cognitive ease
and tribalism and echo chambers although
it is there is a thank goodness a
somewhat of a footing in nuance in multi
variability in equanimity in just
rebirthing the public intellectual hmm
that's even that's our tag with this oh
wow I didn't know that I feel so honored
I'm like so in total the rebirth of the
public is very strong it is it's great
so okay where were where we pre I don't
know oh you're doing integral theory
that adolescent midlife crisis another
sort of formulation well no I mean I
think the important thing for me is that
and I think the the important thing for
a lot of people especially when they hit
that second one in integral theory
there's only
a small percentage of the population
that gets to that level is at that level
and which it calls tier to roughly
maximum kind of 2% of the population is
there and for a lot of those people
they're like I'm done with society I'm
going off to be a hermit or a monk or
write my thing do art or whatever that's
part of the that's part of the model and
a lot of people probably most people I
would say I think Terri O'Fallon would
say most people get up into that and
then it's so kind of overwhelming they
do slide back it is extremely
overwhelming yeah have you been in the
10-day meditation retreats for posture
oh yeah you have I'm a huge opponent
grid in fact I that's my first some of
my first philanthropic Bitcoin work was
bounties for people who would complete
that course for the first time oh that's
great that's so good and you just came
back for my fourth one a couple days ago
yes and one goes there with the UM yes
no technology no talking you know eye
contact and it's incredible and it's
like it's so profoundly fascinating the
way your creativity can you be in bytes
by itself and you train your mind and
focus and everything and then you know
you consider you consider the monk you
consider the nun you consider yeah doing
the complete silence and stuff and you
consider this radicalism and stuff and
they're there it's interesting how many
people consider and then how many people
pull the trigger I just wanted to wanted
to say that I say yeah so what is what
does it mean to lose a 2% go to that
level of yeah wanting to focus on their
own yeah and I mean what we're talking
about here are sort of stages of ego
development is one way to think about it
so get to that state and in or get to
that level and part of the thing about
being at that level is you're not so
into social niceties you're not so into
some serious nodding okay I have to
decide to say this I recently started
contemplating I think it was over the
meditation retreat what if instead of
with the first $30,000 instead of buying
a Tesla you gave 30 artists each $1,000
mm-hmm how would society drastically
change by doing something like then yeah
you plant these seeds or trees whose
shade you don't expect to sit in yeah
and what would happen yeah and I'm just
I'm so fascinated by that and I really
excited to propagate a culture like that
I love you you want and your will people
can still have Tesla's what is you know
what yeah anyway we've talked about
conspicuous consumption a lot enough
with the third yacht's the third
mansions right in the seam Nicholas
Taleb wrote like something about like
there is nothing more like eerie than
the sound of an empty mansion on us made
me shiver a little on the inside yeah
yeah you already feel that way in your
one-bedroom apartment when it's like by
your near by yourself and you're like
like there's no community and imagine
being in that big of a place anyway
anyway yeah interesting what one of the
one things though about that transition
is that you become much more let's say
intuitive is one one word much more in
sort of tune with nature and tune with
what's going on with other people you're
getting all sorts of signals and
downloads
the cosmos that you're trying to make
sense of and you know if you don't have
a community around you who is there and
has done that and has been there then
you know it's pretty easy to think wow
I'm like losing my mind and I mean you
know if you're a seeker like I think we
both are then at least you can probably
hit the library and like take me to the
mysticism section and help me figure out
what's going on here for me
kind of thing right and so you do that
right and I mean that takes you but you
don't spend much time there before you
end up on the path to meditation the
link there is really really clear and
apparent yes and then with any luck and
fortunately you know I've been extremely
lucky as far as I can tell you know
really you find a community that has
been through this and has is there and
understands what's going on has a model
to account for it and not for me is what
the intrical community combined with
sort of classical Buddhism manages to do
for me in my life I have that community
as well yeah yeah for sure and then you
know once once you've grounded a bit
which takes a while for me it took like
2 years everybody goes through a known
good intuitive no that's a that's a
fairly advanced yes that's fairly we
don't want to say advanced or higher
really there's a lot of levers here
around this it's leveling that low but
it's also just I think it's the the
phrase I prefer for it is like later
stages of development so definitely not
everyone's gonna get there I'm sorry
Trump is never gonna get there not in
this lifetime
unless we can you know I don't know do
something like really intervene on that
guy
so so wait this is I'm such a logical
person I love math and I love
probability and I love demographics so
what would you say are the percentage of
people that make it to late stage yeah
late stage and let's just let's just
call it integral and I mean I think I
think the figures and really the
authority here I would say are is would
probably be like Terry O'Fallon from
Pacific integral she's someone that I've
thought I've trained with or probably
Suzanne Cooke writers although I'm less
familiar with her work but hers is very
much around ego development and sort of
tracking and understanding these these
these stages Wilber provided the sort of
overarching framework the other thing
that he's done which is really really
nice if you haven't read any Wilbur I
really recommend I think you know I
usually recommend integral psychology
that's a starting point you know because
I think for any of us having a
conversation like this we're already
interested in psychology and we probably
studied some psychology and what he does
there is he really does a beautiful job
in my mind and giving you an
easy-to-understand introduction to
integral theory which he's developed you
know in much greater extension in
earlier books and then showing how it
applies to the field of psychology in
particular for addressing some of the
kinds of you know mental wellness and
depression anxiety and sort of classical
yeah it's around that showing how it
relates to you know Union psychotherapy
yes to some extent Freud although he's
much more of a union and then and then
but one of the one of the beautiful
things that Wilbur does which is really
I think is really sort of one of his
central gifts is he then shows a sort of
a cross-cultural spiritual development
or psychological development work that's
come from other cultures for example the
Hindus have a psychology the Buddhists
have a psychology
these other cultures that have had a
long time to examine those stuff and
they've also come to very similar kind
of ideas around the structures and the
fact that you can't become you can't go
straight to enlightenment as a meditator
without going through reaching certain
signposts or certain goals along the way
right that's just the way it works yes
and so you know the the levels build
upon each other and the the phrase that
that he's captured is we transcend and
include when we move so we don't reject
what was there before us
yeah our job is to bring that with us
while we open up to a larger
understanding of the cosmos and our
relationship see it's it seems to me
that the way that you're speaking about
transcending and including is the it
could potentially be the next the next
evolution of human biology that that is
the next form of natural selection is
that the ones that transcend and include
transcend and include and continue that
sort of evolution are are the is the
next part of the evolution and then
there's this kind of like this the sense
of fear that I that I used to have when
I used to speak a lot more about
bifurcation of the species into the
ocean wealthy and the ultra poor and and
especially with exponential technologies
and whatnot and so that that that
mentality if if people carry if people
still carry a occasionally I'll just
throw a little a little needle in the
haystack and I'll say something along
the lines of well maybe it goes against
evolutionary pressure for me to give
someone on the street twenty dollars and
that's [ __ ] up and it is it's really
[ __ ] up but um but it's also it's a
it's a it's it's altruism that one
ever be reciprocated and that is
something in evolutionary biology that
typically does not work out for the
fitness of the of the person that is
attempting to potentially if you're
trying to benevolently impact billions
of people and give them sustainability
and energy and education and yours for
some reason distracted by giving people
on the streets 20 bucks or food or
whatever that you may not attain a
certain level of fitness with wine with
what you can achieve with impacting the
world because you were focused it's kind
of like the hole you're having a kid
instead of focusing on mimetics and on
some bigger picture stuff so there's all
this nuance to that conversation but I
like how you said transcend and include
transcend and include that's very
interesting and another one that I think
you'd like is whenever whenever I hear
the superiority complex our eyes even
within myself still I I just start
thinking colors colors on a color wheel
colors on a color wheel all colors not
blue is better than pink is better than
green right better than or right just
colors on a color wheel and the wheel is
very important right it's not a
hierarchy wheel and the wheel even spins
yeah you know whatever color you want
facing up this is interesting
okay so continue where you were at yeah
in integral theory and how that relates
to I really I just want to make sure we
talk about data yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
and let's so let's roll into after that
move down to the conference of the MIT
yeah yeah quantified self here for cars
great yeah toe toe I mean just just to
sort of wrap up I guess a little bit
about my sex spiritual crisis allowing
allowing that to sort of lead me into
finding a community and finding in
particular this model with this
understanding and this developmental
theory was very helpful and then I think
I yeah I don't know if this is human
tendency or I mean I think I think it's
probably is human nature of it that you
know when we feel when we feel gratitude
for something we want to give back to
that and so I feel a fair bit of
gratitude for that community and that
that model for helping me understand
what was going on for myself in a way
that was not pathologizing it was you
know extremely liberating to to do that
and so it's like okay well there's
something that I think others could
benefit from right I mean it's like it's
like the passion right when I came out
of my first passion I was like everyone
should do this I've modified that
somewhat now I think if you're at risk
of psychosis probably you shouldn't do
it but pretty much everyone else should
do it and and that was the nature of my
my bounty program was like spreading the
word like hey go do this and you know so
and and so looking at ways that it can
give back believing in the sort of the
veracity and the utility of the model
because the model one of the things that
I find really wonderful about the model
is it's both descriptive in that it
describes the world and the way the
world is and helps make sense of it but
it's also prescriptive right if you have
this sort of this this maturation that
we go through naturally and it makes
sense because you're moving towards more
loving more open taking on additional
perspectives in the decision-making that
you're doing you getting to a place
where you can flow with much more
equanimity through situations and make
decisions I mean why wouldn't we want
everyone to be there doing that and if
there's and if there's an understanding
oh you're gonna go through a series of
crises but oh here's practices and
things that will help you through these
crises so it's not such a crisis as it
was for me it's more of a you know a
little hiccup or a little speed bump
there rather than I'm
my god two years you know flailing
around wondering what's going on then I
mean it just makes sense that that's
what I should be doing with my time and
so and being a computer geek having this
understanding of the world you know apps
and their power and what can be done
with them I have to admit I've watched
this whole social media thing with quite
a bit of concern I just deleted my
Twitter account after ten years never
been on Facebook and played around a
little bit here and there but I'm just
not convinced especially in its current
form and part of it is you know as we've
seen that you know it's just way too
easy for BOTS armies to command these
things and control these things right
and so we need to take a serious issue
at you know how can we make these so
they can't be manipulated in this way we
all want to have genuine communication
and come a kosygin's together and to use
the amazing power that the internet
brings to us but it can't be controlled
by robot armies and all this kind of
stuff and in this way and scammers you
know I mean if you spend any time in the
cryptocurrency space it's just rife with
scammers especially you know when when
the markets are you know doing their
thing that they did last year which by
the by the way it was like the fifth one
of those that I've been through so I'm
Jill so so you know data and data
ownership where data gets produced and I
mean and also not wanting to lose sight
of wow there's really amazing things
that we can do with data now right like
the data that's being collected from the
hardware devices and various things at
this conference is amazing right and we
want to utilize that to the best
possible way and so the human data
Commons foundation is comes out of this
there's amazing ways that we can combine
and use data there
very destructive ways that data can be
used there's all sorts of privacy and
ethical concerned this is a very you
know this is a burgeoning field an
active discussion that's happening now
I'm super thrilled to see it happening
you know I'm just heard over herds you
know so many conversations here about
data privacy and where is it stored and
all this kind of stuff which is just
music to my ears and and so playing some
sort of coordinating role in how that
can happen so that we get the best
possible results and eliminate the worst
possible results is the purpose of the
human data Commons foundation I love it
the there was a completely digital AI
reporter and that was on the video it
was trying to China yes just all that
one yeah so it's it's hilarious because
they is released as a you know a digital
reporter for now and then soon it'll be
she should paying right yeah or the
president of China or it will be the
Donald Trump or will be yellow musk or
whatever it'll just be leading figures
and so here's data being used in a way
that is manipulative then there's you
who's saying that
let's pool together our efforts and
resources and knowledge and find ways to
put together the data in ways that are
positive and benefit Evelyn and helpful
yeah beneficial to humanity and and when
I think about that I think about how
even if the good actors do their thing
there still needs to be some sort of a
way for bad actors to not be able to do
yeah yeah yeah it's it's a real
challenge and no one's figured it out
for sure I mean I think there's I think
there are some interesting technological
solutions we should be looking at but
you know that's only part of it only
part of it is you know can we bring the
engineering mindset
- I think homomorphic encryption is a
very interesting possibility for you
know storing data much more safely and
yet still allowing us to draw the
inferences out of it that we can use for
a machine learning and statistical
analysis that's that's one you know
apples you know a leader in differential
privacy which is sort of another
statistical approach to how you might be
able to you know use the insights that
you can get out of large amounts of data
while still protecting the privacy of
the individual that's another blockchain
I think is interesting as well and I'm
you know fairly knowledgeable in that
area and and have I'm actually a venture
capitalist in several firms that are
doing interesting stuff like ocean
protocol I don't know if you're familiar
with that one or hollow chain is an
interesting approach as well there but
that's that's not the whole of it I
don't think I don't think you know I
think it's got a work hand-in-hand with
with a process that is much more
inclusive because all of those that we
just go back to the integral model all
of those reside in the lower-right as
technologies where's musical theory says
you get the most complete picture and
you get the best basis for what we may
call the right decision is if you
examine it from all four quadrants
that's what we need to do and so you
know the real the real piece that you
know human data Commons is doing and
it's sort of my personal passion is - is
what we call interval praxis how can we
get those people who are collecting data
working data making decisions around
they'd
to use a process that's much more
inclusive much more holistic to make the
decisions about yeah so so one of the
one of the good Segway yeah
one of one of the artifacts and one of
one of the ways that we approach this is
to we produce an annual report card on
the quantified self industry so we go
through sort of the top players last
year I think there was 50 in our report
so we just you know we you know go from
everyone from Google and their Google
health and you know Garmin Strava and
you know some some of the big names
Fitbit and so on and so forth down to
many smaller players as well and of
course the this field is growing so
there's more stuff all the time some of
the ones that I see at the conference
here are in our report we're in our
report last year and are also in our
report this year last year was a very it
was our first one and it was a very
subjective report so we really looked at
it from the perspective of somebody
coming wanting to use the service and
what their experience would be with
understanding the privacy policy
understanding how the data was being
used what they were getting in return
for that data and this year we've
brought a much more of a quantified
approach to it in that we brought in a
statistician to help us you know sort of
ramp up the quantified side of it so
it's it's much more balanced in nuanced
and then let's talk about what is some
of the questions are yeah so I mean the
main questions are what what rights do
you give up when you use this service or
use this hardware and the data that's
being collected from it what control do
you have over the data that's in there
is is it respecting of your privacy or
you know those data just disappear and
you have no idea what happens to it or
how it's being used is that how it's
being used and stored and all that kind
of stuff being told to you in clear
language that you can understand and not
66 pages exactly so we're rating all of
these companies on exactly all of these
things and then the last one which is
kind of near and dear to my heart in
terms of the project that we just
mentioned which is the ability to
aggregate this data and draw you know
insights from from you know combining it
with other data sources is is that a
feature or a function that the site or
service allows you to do can you export
your data out of there or can you say
hey Garmin share my data in real time
with these other services or even like
provide me with my own API to query that
day that myself because I want to build
something on it so so they get it they
get an overall score for how they rate
on on all of those those things yeah
because yeah I mean for obvious reasons
I mean you know we're the directions
that we want to go with with this data
and for and also a big part of the of
the report card is to show who's doing
the best show who's doing the worst show
where you are in that and I you know the
hope is people look and go wow clue
which is a European I don't know if you
know the clue it's a it's a it's a it's
a device for women actually and produced
by women and it has by far that the best
score in part I think because quite
frankly I think it's a company and that
it's European as well is like seems to
be the killer combination in terms of
you know doing all the right things in
all the right way you you mentioned this
earlier I want to know more about clue I
was just I was just thinking about how
ridiculous it is that we can't query our
own day
and yeah yeah and B I think I want to
make things with my day exactly exactly
yeah yeah and I mean and I mean this is
the kind of the worst ranks the worst
it's a it's a Chinese advertise which
produces a wearable right and so yeah
why don't why do the companies fill out
what's their incentive to fill out the
fire oh they don't fill it out
oh no we go in research oh yeah
though the only thing we want from the
company is quite frankly is you know if
there's a company that wants to be
included we would love to know about
them right so there's probably a bunch
here that are not in our program we
weren't aware of them all so I mean we
actually have fewer companies that we
examine this year because of GDP our
what we found is during our research
period we were you know doing our
research you know collating the data and
stuff and then when we went back for a
second pass through to just verify
because that's part of our methodology
right is to have to two sets of eyes on
it and stuff lo and behold a bunch of
stuff had changed well it was gdpr
right there was a whole rush of you know
changes that needed to be made in
policies and all that kind of stuff as a
response to JD PR so it'll be
interesting to see what the results look
like next year actually - because I
where can we find the oh it's it's all
available for download no nothing
required human data Commons org you'll
see it right on there on the front page
yeah I'm links in the bio go check out
human data Commons organ which I doubt
the quantified self report card it's
brilliant I love it I want to know if
it's okay I'll just drop two more things
that were yeah and I want it and then I
want to know you're long your long term
vision
the day of data and yam and yet what
would be ideal because it sounded like
that the highest scores on the report
cards might be ideal so yeah yeah we
haven't mentioned the conference right
as I was you're gonna know there's
actually sort of two other will you talk
about the conference a little bit if you
want but but you can you know to get a
good sense in Vancouver it happens in
Vancouver we've held it in August last
years but this year we're actually
moving into the spring so that it
actually doesn't conflict with the
research period on the report card as
well because we are a small staff yeah
it was kind of doubling up yeah both at
the same time we want the report card to
continue to come out in the fall because
then our sort of our social media
campaign or our PR campaign around it is
to try and make it part of purchasing
decisions for Christmas presidents
fantastic yep applying that kind of
pressure yeah just it's not just you
know beating with a stick it's like hey
this is fantastic you should you're
considering this buy this product
instead of this other product because
it's it's so interesting that that if we
can eventually have a star rating system
[Laughter]
that's exactly so that's that's
something that's being sort of back in
my mind for a while is and I mean the
the model that I I think comes closest
is the leads system for buildings for
building sustainability you know it's a
voluntary system you know it's well
understood it's not super complicated
you know you're looking at buying a
place or leasing an office LEED Gold
well it's easy to look up and see what
that means and and you know and it's
consequently because it's not something
at least in most jurisdictions that's
legislated it really has been a hey you
know do this because it's the right
thing to do right and so I mean at least
in Vancouver now all the buildings these
days have are saying what their lead
certification is right and
you know the top top leads are the ones
that people want right because they want
to be identified with that so we're
looking at implementing you know with
that sort of voluntary notion right and
making it a standard which is like a
community standard rather than you know
just some imposed from above kind of
thing and you know I know it's a
community kind of like crowd-sourced
yeah yeah yeah yeah decentralized as
much as possible really you did yeah
yeah interesting and then what was the
other one so the other one which is is
which I can't speak with great authority
of because it's actually not my idea
it's actually the idea of Rochelle
Fairfield who's our executive director
and so her on the show and she's never
on the show yeah that would be great
to talk about this idea in particular so
so you know data is is the basis for
machine learning yeah right that's in
part why there's such a rush to get our
hands on as much of it as possible all
right and machine learning and you know
the possibilities of a and how AI gets
used and sort of examining some of the
existential risks around where it's
maybe going and Elon Musk is you know
really really big into this as well and
it's pretty controversial but you know
we we think that there are going to be
some big problems that come out of AI
and and to some extent we're seeing some
of the smaller ones I don't know if you
saw the the the Amazon thing about a
month ago where Amazon had created this
this machine learning AI thing to scour
the web looking for candidates to
approached about hiring and so they at
least you know released the AI go get us
candidates and it comes back and
somebody you know I don't know how long
they've been running it they've been
running it for a while actually and you
know so it was part of their hiring
process right like this it's the lead
gen it's doing a lot of stuff lo and
behold somebody does analysis
well things completely biased against
women
like there's you know all other things
being equal it's it's so they've got you
know that was basically a sexist AI that
they were using said well what kind of a
position were they looking forward
everything you know I mean there's a lot
of other variable oh there's a lot of
other variables but you know ostensibly
you know when it was revealed that this
was what was going on they actually
there to their credit their response was
verify those results and were like oh
this is right and they pulled it so it's
it's out of their process so I mean
that's just like I might not not a
completely minor example but it's an
example of you know an AI that's been
developed based upon data and set off to
do its thing causing a problem
right I mean you know it's yes it's
increasing the the the economic
disenfranchisement to women to some
extent right Amazon or ever just
minority groups around the world or
other examples so and I mean there's a
there's a really important study or book
on this by a woman by the name of called
weapons of mass destruction
mmm-hmm so she is another sort of
statistician who's gone through and
collected lots of examples these things
these algorithms which come out of
machine learning and you know based upon
data that are doing you know leading to
unjust policies and unjust
unjust procedures so you know to some
extent you know now's the time to be
tackling this now is the time to be
talking about this now is the time to be
coming up with a more complete way of
building these things and that's what
again what I think integral praxis
really brings in to these kinds of
things it's also knowing thyself knowing
myself I mean will I think maybe we can
rap with you you've all know a Harare
his uh you know his his claim that we
you know we need to know ourselves
better that's the only way that we're
gonna be able to resist the manipulation
that's you know coming at us now and is
just gonna get even better and better
and better because of all of the data
and everything being collected under
said knowing ourselves both on an
individual basis and also knowing the
forces that may be attempting nipple aid
us and also knowing the as best as we
can making communal sense making and
with that then having some sort of a
layer of foundation that we can move
forward with as we attempt to be
stewards of this earth yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the final idea just so I can
wrap up this is a what we're tenderly
calling an AI cleanup fund and so it's
perfect ocean clean up clean up yeah
yeah so I mean I don't know how familiar
you are with the u.s. Superfund program
right yeah so Superfund I mean so during
during the industrial revolution you
know there was all of these like
industrial sites set up all over America
right like chemical plants and then
those companies went out of business but
they left just oh yeah Massa
that's very problem right and so the
government's response to this and I
think it was probably Jimmy Carter I
would guess I don't know who else it
would have been not that there were
other fine presence was the creation of
and who knows maybe it was Reagan
vacation of what they called Superfund
and so it was this massive pile of money
to clean up to clean up these things
where you couldn't you know there was
nobody left to see that's an easier
thing to clean up because it's as though
the bad actors aren't you gotta come and
open those up again yeah yeah but with
an AI ya Superfund you may have bad
actors just totally there's a lot of
things we work out and I mean we in part
you know this is this is
this is my PR background lighting up
here because what I like about even the
idea of an AI cleanup fund is the effect
it has on people just when they hear oh
there's an AI cleanup fund what does
that mean it means there's gonna be a
mess from AI very likely that needs to
be cleaned up so it's already having
like a home in clay Church it's really
exact that that's a big point ai cleanup
fund and then people are like oh it's oh
it's a more notion that it's a problem
in many ways I like that yeah or it
could be a problem or we should at least
have some insurance for things that may
come out of it which are the unintended
consequences of yes what we've done what
is your long-term view on data I like to
think of a world where the data is all
completely transparent and it's all
completely to be able to used in
whatever way possible that there's even
if your meta transcriptomics and yours
and Pallas and etc are all available
then I don't think that it is um it
could potentially make it easier for us
to just have data as a as an open yeah I
mean the issue I think is there are
going to be and you've all know re you
know calls them he's like there's
corporations and governments that want
to manipulate you and you know the more
data they have the easier it is to
manipulate well there's also a level of
leveling up and consciousness that
occurs that those companies hopefully by
Millennials and gems years and even
younger people that are coming in that
say that we will not be a part of what
you're going yeah yeah hopefully that's
what happens because then yeah then they
die for for not changing for not yeah
yep and I mean I think what we're seeing
with Facebook right now is
interesting I'm sure you probably saw
the stat like 44% of like what is it 18
to 29 year olds have deleted the app off
their phone in the last year's like
really 44% in America but I mean if
that's true that's I mean there's got to
be yeah we can out it yeah yeah the the
they have a lot of other interesting
trains that are going like with virtual
reality and yeah yeah there's there's a
lot of other things that are going on
there that but I but I agree with you I
think yeah so I think I think we're I
think that would that was that was
SuperDuper deep across not only human
data Commons but also just the just the
sheer like playfulness of us being able
to talk about about leveling up and
about all the nuance there that there's
just really good to be able to sit down
with a Scot that was yes antastic
likewise top notch I was yeah III should
say you know the other the other thing
you know in terms of the the notion of
leveling up I am somewhat sympathetic to
[Music]
one of the people that I work with in
this area I mean I don't work with them
directly but you know he is a figure and
you know he's quite concerned about the
notion of leveling up because he feels
that to even hold that notion to carry
that notion is a form of violence it is
yeah yeah yeah so you know that's and I
haven't I mean I just bring that up
because I think it's I think it has to
be part of the discussion as well so I
mean so could seeing things as a
hierarchy could be viewed as it's like a
violent for sure for sure yeah okay yeah
okay but I mean at least I mean the
integral model I mean it it it
acknowledges hierarchies exist and says
they make perfect sense in certain
circumstances
right and in certain conditions right
yeah I think it's yeah that's that's
appropriate and it's I know that's
ultimately the same way for you can
apply similar thinking around data and
how it gets used and how much control
we're gonna give yeah you know yeah so
yes thank you thank you yes thank you
for part of on such a vibrant discussion
yeah antacid yeah likewise this is where
you based are you here downtown San
Francisco okay to do is okay yeah and
you are thank over North
yeah when when some when you're smart
people come down here we'll feature them
when we go up there will ya future your
company Bank over well we get a part
time next year yeah I would love I would
love that I would love yeah we could do
some great interviews yeah there would
be a lot of fun in the spring coming up
then so yes with Rochelle are awesome
our idea the report card is coming up
right then the report card is was
released last Friday so it's it's a card
that we released last Friday fantastic
yeah only go check it out links in the
bio everyone thanks for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it give us a give us
your thoughts in the comments we'd love
to hear from you also definitely go and
build build build go create go manifest
your dreams build the future thanks
everyone for tuning in much love and we
will see you soon
[Music]